this pitcher Nix is 23 years old he's
playing in the Arizona folly
can you imagine what goes on in the
locker room now after he's arrested for
trying to sneak into somebody's house
through a doggie door I mean who knows
what was involved you know there could
have been could have been some drinking
going on could have been some edibles
who knows what was involved but he's a
doggy door that's crazy
Wow you know I guarantee I guarantee I
would I would bet a a year's salary not
very much but I bet a year's salary the
Bruce Feldman who's on the blind now has
never tried to sneak into somebody's
house through a doggie door Bruce Bruce
Feldman who writes for the athletic he's
a reporter for Fox has the audible
podcast with Stu and Bruce out of those
three things Bruce what do you garner
the most joy from is it the podcast is
it the writing or is it being at the
games on the sidelines it's being at the
games on the sidelines I mean I love all
those other things but you know they all
kind of go together but just to be I
mean I love college ball every bit it's
not more and when I first started doing
this and just to be able to do that you
know that's that's the best thing it
never gets old I love that and of course
you're in Eugene for Colorado and Oregon
tonight on fs1 is that correct yes
7 o'clock local time tonight should be
fun off to the stadium never disappoints
all right I'm gonna ask you about that
game in just a minute but I want to run
down some of the some of the key games
here between ranked teams the the Red
River showdown can't call to shoot out
anymore noon on Fox Oklahoma Texas
Oklahoma coming in ranked 6 Texas is 11
at the Cotton Bowl I know you've been on
Texas since before the season started
but but you like Oklahoma in this one
according to your most recent column has
that changed yeah you know what I mean
we had we had old
oh you a couple of weeks you know was
really about Jalen Hurd's and that
offenses has been also Texas the
secondary which got lit up by Joe burrow
and LSU
week two they are really banged up so
not only were they really inexperienced
now they're really banged up on top of
it I think it's gonna be hard for as
terrific as sam.callender is i think
it's gonna be hard for them to keep up
you know when as depleted as they are on
defense right now
Lincoln Riley is this quarterback savant
you know he's the kind of the latest hot
ticket item for it really any NFL job
that's gonna be open including the
Redskins they talk about Lincoln Riley
I mean Baker Mayfield won the Heisman
Trophy he transferred in Kyler's Murray
won the Heisman Trophy he transferred it
Jalen Hertz is tracking any pole or
anybody you talked to he's one of the
the top two or three guys right now in
terms of the running for the Heisman
what is it about Lincoln Riley that
makes him so effective with these
quarterbacks that he hasn't had for four
years that just kind of come in and had
this immediate success well I think what
he's really really good at is he's a
terrific field for play calling and I
think people know he has area roots but
he is not doing a lot of the same AIRAID
stuff I think he's got some really good
assistant coaches around a bill be Tebow
might be the best offensive line coach
in college football he's really good
with the run game and I think he and
Lincoln are very creative and I think
you know a little bit like Sean Payton
I'm sorry it was not just something
charming Bay with the Rams you have guys
who have a great perspective on who
they're attacking and what might work
and I think his feel for that and
keeping it all relatively simple for his
players to go play free I think he's
been able to do that and look let's not
get ourselves bakers super talented
Kyler super talented Jalen Hurd's has
really gifted so I mean right now this
might be the best collection of
receivers Oklahoma's ever had released
in this and this great run they've been
on so I think it all fits together
really well and and like you've seen a
team that's playing with a lot of
confidence and look just I know the
[ __ ] thing came up I'd be really
stunned if Lincoln Riley who has
probably the porch for the best ad in
college sports right now and Joe
Castiglione would leave that situation
to go war
for the kind of ownership that the
Redskins have with Dan Schneider I just
don't see him making that kind of
business decision at all sometimes the
grass isn't always greener I would be
surprised as well but you never know I
don't know if it depends on money I
don't know if it depends on just his
overall happiness there but it looks
like he's in a pretty good situation you
talk about the receivers at Oklahoma
being good I don't know that I've seen a
receiving corps as good as the one at
Alabama in quite some time I mean I'm at
a Smith was just bananas against Ole
Miss with 274 yards and five touchdowns
number one ranked Alabama taking on
Texas A&M does am have a shot being
that's at home they have an outside
outside shot and in Kevin mountains a
good quarterback and Jimbo Fisher's
really certainly a really good coach I
just don't think they're good enough and
ready on both sides of the ball on the
line of scrimmage to handle Alabama to
stay with them for four quarters I mean
you know you're right that is a great
group of receivers to a has McGarry
duties probably the most dynamic after
the catch guy they just have a ton of
firepower and you know I just don't see
them being able to hang with hang with
the tide for four quarters I think maybe
a year from now this matchup will be a
little different because - and some of
those receivers have begun I think
you're moldy and you're three but right
now I just think it's too much of an
uphill climb for the Aggies so you
talked about Jerry Judy Devante Smith
Henry rugs all five-star recruits coming
out of high school I was racking my
brain trying to think of you know just
in the last I don't know 10 15 years a
better trio you know in school I came up
with a couple a couple of lists here
okay I want to run him by you
Ohio State no 607 had Santonio Holmes
Ted Ginn Anthony Gonzales all
first-round picks Miami had Santana Moss
and Reggie Wayne and then Andre King who
was a seventh round pick and then LSU
had the year where they had Michael
Clayton Devery Henderson in and Josh
Reed is there another receiving core you
know in recent history that stands out
to you that was as
dynamic as this receiving court Alabama
right now well I would put the
combination of Zach Mettenberger had at
LSU just with Landry and Odell Beckham
it's just it was a big drop-off for the
next guy they're guys who played in the
NFL what's crazy is as good as this
Alabama group is and I mean also in the
SEC West right now you have Justin
Jefferson who's who's been fantastic he
was a like a low three star guy who's
blown up and been a great player for
them they have Jamar chase who's
probably deep breakout player and the
SEC this year and terrorist Marshall was
hurt but those guys and the terrorists
Marshall parties back in a couple of
weeks those guys as a threesome with in
that offense they rival that group
Clemson's loaded you know I was thinking
USC had a bunch when it was then
marquise Lee has not been a great NFL
player but you look at had a great run
Robert would they have had a run of
really really good receivers but you
know you can throw what clemson had you
know you've had some big super athletic
receivers there it's just hard to it's
hard to to be honest sometimes these
guys blur together where somebody was
really really great there last year but
probably a role player when the other
guys were kind of rolling it's just hard
I think have them all going off at one
time the way it seems like Alabama has
with two right now
yeah you bring up Clemson is Sammy
Watkins martavis Bryant you know Adam
Humphries was there Andre yeah of course
it's unbelievable what they've done
there let's let's visit the SEC for a
minute here the eight o'clock game on
Saturday night on ESPN is seventh ranked
Florida undefeated at LSU also
undefeated two of four undefeated teams
right now in the SEC Florida of course
coming off that win over then seventh
ranked Auburn the gator defense is
pretty stout they're all gonna have to
deal with LSU's number one ranked
scoring offense averaging 54 points per
game though is LSU two touchdowns better
than Florida they're favored by 13 and a
half in this game
I don't think they are I think Florida's
defense is really good now here's why I
think that the experts have it this way
there's to me there's two big factors
that are at play the first one is this
game is that Tiger Stadium at night
Florida quarterback style traps very
limited experience this game is last
week they had fonox kind of a true
freshman not ready to handle the swamp
and that defense well now it's flipped
and you have an older quarterback but no
more experience in Kyle Trask now he's
got to go into an equally hostile
environment you much probably made it
more into the night game there and I
think that's the challenge and the other
factor is this kind of back end of a
one-two punch being they played a big
physical opponent last week the
emotional rush to play over and they
were an underdog they won the game now
they got to play an even more talented
team with a better offense maybe not a
been a better deal eye but a better much
better offense and probably equal
personnel on defense say for the
defensive line part of it and that game
is on the road it's at night and when
you look back and I saw this is
something we talked about on the audible
this week and I saw Chris FeliCa really
from gameday buttoned it up with a
pretty amazing stat in the last 12 times
a a ranked team has played one of these
kinds had this dynamic which is play a
ranked team as an underdog and then beat
them and then you got to go on the road
to play another rowing team that team is
1 and 11 in those games that's why it
just does not bode well for Dan Mullen
in Florida that's kind of situation I'm
glad you brought that set up I saw that
in your column very interesting stuff
there Joe burrow to me has been one of
the more fascinating players in college
football loses the job basically to
Dwane Haskins at Ohio State was a
graduate transfer goes to LSU plays last
year was good not great but nobody in
college football this season has made
themselves more money than Joe burrow 22
touchdown passes already Pro Football
Focus has him rated as the best
quarterback in college football
you see in Joe Burrell and do you think
that he could be the first quarterback
taken I don't know on that end if he
give you that you know there's there's
some other guys we're gonna have
probably bigger arms but when you're
looking what he's doing here's the stuff
that I know I know that LSU staff pretty
well and they love his leadership how
competitive he is and how smart he is
and the last piece of that is in terms
of how he picked up they brought it had
probably as big a coaching addition as
anybody made this year and it was a guy
almost nobody knew about Joe Brady who
was a at the time 29 year old he was an
assistant with the Saints but not even a
position coach and he had learned under
Joel Moore had a Penn State and then
went to go work for Sean Payton that guy
is the past game coordinator in the
receivers coach and he has changed
everything in LSU and it's all been for
the better and when you see them hitting
the gas and having all these these big
passing days it's because of what Joel
Brady brought joke Burrell picked it up
really really well I think it suits him
very well and now this will be a big
test for them to play Florida on this
defense but right now he's a legit
Heisman candidate this is different than
any LSU we have seen in a long long time
and he runs the system really well and I
think it's there's a lot of NFL concepts
I mean he's a guy who probably was
looked at like as a free agent prospect
and now I would not be surprised if he
became a first-round pick somewhere in
the first round just because how well
he's running this system it's funny how
that works isn't it you mentioned Joe
Brady wide receiver coach you know this
I'm sure last wide receiver coach to
make a jump into the head coaching ranks
and then a win a couple of national
championships at Florida and Ohio State
when your counterparts now at Fox that's
right yeah I mean he's he's younger than
Urban Meyer his there's a lot rhetoric
but he is a guy who if there's one guy
who generated a ton of buzz I mean we
did a big story arm on the athletic in
the offseason I dote on the head coach
had told me
they've been raving about this guy's
when I went out them in the spring and
you have all this buzz around them
inside the program and I remember
writing the story what you get from a
lot of people a lot of readers and then
people on the internet would be like oh
yeah we've heard it before Ellis she was
changing the offense I heard this five
different time for Les Miles was there
but you know what this time it is all
been true and I think just watch the
Texas game and just see what's gone on
there and it's gonna be fun to see what
happens Tiger Stadium I'm still not sure
they can beat out the Alabama in
Tuscaloosa and that's been the big
hurdle for them but so far I mean that
guy has been has been a huge like
whatever he's getting paid it is not
enough in Baton Rouge for what he has
done for that for that program certainly
@osha Ron said he's been waiting to
change this offense and now he has the
pieces in place Bama by the way still
let's play LSU and Auburn coming up
Bruce Feldman on the phone from Fox
Sports and the athletic we were talking
Florida and LSU Joe burrow potential
first-round draft pick quarterback for
LSU now you're calling are you will be
on the sidelines for the Colorado Oregon
game tonight on fs1 Justin Herbert has
been kind of the consensus first or
second quarterback off the board for the
last year or so along with tua this this
guy has all the tools I mean six six he
has the arm he has the intelligence what
have you seen
you know from Justin Herbert that could
translate into the NFL well he's got it
he's got a terrific arm like you said
he's very smart he's also really
athletic Khomeini's he moves really well
for being 240 pounds I think that the
two areas of question I want people are
gonna say hey how come they're not
putting up even bigger numbers of half
game and I think one of the challenges
for them is last week we had them
against a cow and they got three of
their best receivers back from injury
had missed most of the year and those
guys are a little rusty so let's see
what happens now that there's some time
to get those guys those are the three
best weapon the other part of it which
is a little bit of a wild card with with
Justin Herbert is just his demeanor I
mean he's he's a brilliant kid he's a
very nice humble
I think there's some questions about
just how many is fair to say questions
but I guess just about how much of a
commanding presence he is not the Lala
kind of personality it doesn't mean he
can't be a really good NFL quarterback
in lead team's manera been guys who have
not had that kind of ultra alpha
personality but he's just so you know
it's just a little different in that
regard I mean to be honest Marcus
Mariota had not a similar demeanor and I
just think that sometimes because the
guy has all the physical tools and
there's no off field character question
mark there's people are always going to
find something to take issue with and I
think I suspect that will be ii think
people will take issue with and and look
when you asked all the oregon coaches
and his teammates the biggest thing they
say is this guy has so much credibility
with his teammates because they know how
hard he works and how much he cares same
questions still to this day about Marcus
Mariota he called the Titans preseason
games and they still ask those questions
about Marcus Eli Manning had those
questions coming out throughout his
career he won two Super Bowls Bruce
Feldman from the athletic and Fox Sports
he's gonna be on the sidelines for the
Colorado Oregon game tonight on fs1
Bruce also my neighbor in Manhattan
Beach thanks for coming on the show
Bruce much appreciated my friend I
appreciate the time all right talk to
you soon and have a good call in the
game tonight that's Bruce Feldman for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app